Nous sommes ensemble comme ça depuis notre naissance
J'ai l'impression de vivre maintenant
Cela a toujours été ainsi, je l'espère.
Nénanka
Une fois que mon stylo s'arrête, mon esprit devient soudainement flou.
ennemi
Cette photo du chef était parfaite.
Tu devrais pouvoir comprendre mon manga
Cela ressemblait à la réalité, juste en dessous de son esprit conscient.
Seul M. Fujita peut entrer.
Il ne faut pas
S'il te plaît, dis-moi, pourquoi as-tu fait ça ?
Il sera remis dans son état d'origine le premier jour de l'année.
Je pense que je vais juste y aller avec ma mère.
C'est peut-être cruel de le dire, mais les lecteurs aussi
J'ai l'impression que tu es vraiment avec moi.
Je suppose que tu veux me revoir
Je ne peux plus me réveiller comme ça
Tu sais, je ne laisserai jamais ça arriver comme ça.
Même si je me réveille, je n'oublierai pas ça
Je me souviens que
De toute façon, la pieuvre est dans ma conscience.
Narun
est